Do you know what a production,
real world, server side WebAssembly application
looks like? The truth is not many do.
Server side WebAssembly is still at the cutting
edge of cloud computing.
And there just aren't enough, perhaps any, examples
of real world production grade server side WebAssembly
applications.
That was until now.
Justin,
a senior solutions engineer at Fermion,
has built himself his own social network using
Spin. So join us as we explore the
code base, add a new feature, and talk
about the experience of writing real world production
grade server side WebAssembly applications using Spin. Click
the link.